PROFESSOR: OK.
So we come to the idea
of countable sets, which
are the most familiar
kind of infinite sets.
And a countable set is one where
you can list the elements-- a0,
a1, a2 and so on.
So there's a list of
all of the elements of A
in which every element in
A appears at some point.
You can count up to
any given element of A,
and every element of A you
will eventually get to,
you'll be able to
count up to it.
So it's just a
matter of listing it.
And the technical definition
of "A is countable"
is if there's a
bijection between A
and the non-negative integers.
Because this listing,
in effect, really
is a mapping from the
non-negative integers to A. 0
is a0, 1 maps to
a1, 2 maps to a2,
and implicitly there's a
bijection being indicated here.
That's assuming that all of the
[? a's ?] are distinct for it
to be a bijection.
So we also have,
as a special case,
the finite sets are also
considered to be countable.
So really, if n is
a bijection to A,
then A is called
countably infinite.
The other possibility
is that A is finite.
And the two together, I
just say A is countable.
So what we've just
figured out, then,
from the previous examples,
is that the positive integers
are countable.
And all the integers
are countable,
because in both cases
we exhibited bijections
to the non-negative integers.
Another important
and not very hard
example is the set of
finite binary words.
So we use this notation,
"0, 1 star," meaning
all the finite-- star means
all the finite sequences
of these elements, 0 and 1.
So this is just the
finite binary words.
How are they countable?
Well, I need a way to be able to
list them in some orderly way.
Well, let's just
do it by length.
Let's begin by listing
the empty word, or string,
of length zero.
And then I'm going to list
all the one-bit strings,
the strings of length one.
And there are two of those.
So let the second element,
the next element of the list
after the empty string, be 0,
and then let the next element
after that be 1.
Then let's list all
the length two strings.
Well, there's four length
two binary strings.
And let's just list them
in some sensible order--
say, by their binary
representation.
And then keep going.
List all the length
three binary strings--
there's eight of those.
And finally, keep going up
until you get to the length n
binary strings, of which
there are 2 to the n.
And this is a description of a
way to list, one after another,
all of the finite binary words,
or finite binary strings.
And that listing is
implicitly a description
of a bijection from the
non-negative integers
n to the nth element
in my listing.
And that's a bijection, so the
binary words are countable.
Another example
of a countable set
is the pairs of
non-negative integers.
So how can-- now I've got
the non-negative integers.
I've got to find a bijection of
pairs of non-negative integers.
How am I going to do that?
Well, it's the same idea as
we used with binary strings.
There's a bunch of
ways to prove it,
but let's just propagate
the binary string idea.
Let's start listing the pairs
of non-negative integers.
And after 0, 0, I'm going to
list two pairs-- 0, 1 and 1, 0.
And after them, I'm going to
list three pairs-- 0, 2, 2, 0,
and 1, 1.
And after them, 0,
3, 3, 0, 1, 2, 2, 1.
And if you can see
what I'm doing,
I'm basically listing the
pairs in the order of the sum
of their coordinates.
So the nth block of pairs
that I'm going to list
will be the pairs the sum of
whose two coordinates is n.
There'll be n plus one of those.
And I keep going in this way.
This is a nice orderly
description of--
or a description of
a nice orderly way
to list all of the pairs
of non-negative integers.
Within a block, invent
some alphabetical rule
for listing the pairs.
So I'm going to--
I've hinted at a rule
here for listing the finite
set of pairs whose sum is n,
and you can invent--
any one will do.
So that tells us that
we have a bijection
between the
non-negative integers
and the pairs of
non-negative integers.
So that's another
important bijection.
Now, when you're trying
to prove countability,
it's very useful to have
the following lemma, which
gives an alternative
characterization
of countability-- namely,
a set A is countable if
and only if you can
list A allowing repeats.
Remember, our
original definition
is that you can list A without
repeats if it's infinite,
or else it's finite.
So that was-- the bijection
between the non-negative
integers and A, in
effect, is saying
that that's a listing of
all of an infinite set A
with no repeats, because it's
a bijection we're mapping.
If an element
appeared twice, we'd
have two different
non-negative integers
mapping to it, which would
break the bijection property,
the injection property.
And so suppose we allow repeats.
And the claim is that that's
fine, because you can fix that.
So the lemma says
that, if there's
a surjective function from the
non-negative integers to A,
then A is countable.
Well, let's just check
quickly in one direction.
If A is finite, then there's
clearly a surjective function
from the non-negative
integers to A.
There's lots of extra
non-negative integers
you don't need.
If it's a finite set,
like 10 elements in A,
map 0 through 9 to
those 10 elements,
and map every other
non-negative integer, say,
to 10th element, or
last element, of A.
So there's certainly a
surjection if A is finite.
Now, suppose that A is infinite,
and I have a surjection
from the non-negative
integers to A.
So I'm listing A with repeats.
And I'm supposed to
have a bijection if it
matches the other definition.
How do you do that?
Well, if you're a
computer scientist,
you know how to change
a sequence with repeats
into a sequence without repeats.
You just filter
it for duplicates,
going from left to right.
Take this infinite
sequence of elements of A
in which there are repeats, and
keep only the first occurrence
of each element.
That will define a bijection
with the non-negative integers
if a is infinite.
And that's how we prove this
lemma, which I'm just going
to settle for talking through.
So now we have
another convenient way
to show that a set is
countable, just by describing,
not a bijection,
but a surjection
between the non-negative
integers in A. Surjections
are often easier to describe
than bijections, which
is why this is a useful lemma.
A corollary of this
is that, if I'm
trying to show that
a set A is countable,
all that I really need to
do is find some other set
that I know to be
countable and describe
a surjection from
that other set C to A.
Because I know that
if C is countable,
then there'll be a bijection
between the non-negative
integers and C. And
since when you combine
a bijection with a surjection,
you wind up with a surjection,
that will implicitly
define a surjection
from the non-negative integers
to A, which by the lemma
tells me that A is countable.
So the general way
to prove something
is countable is just
describe a surjection,
from something you
know to be countable,
that hits your target.
And let's look at
an example of that.
I claim that the
rationals are countable,
the rational numbers
are countable.
Well, this is kind of a little
bit more striking at first,
because you can see
how you can count
the non-negative integers,
the positive integers, all
the integers, because
there's a nice sensible way
to have one come after other.
But with the
rationals, it's messy.
In between any two rationals,
there's another rational.
There isn't any first rational.
There isn't any obvious
way to list them all.
But really, if you stop thinking
about the rationals of how they
are laid out on the real line,
but just think of them as pairs
of integers, then it becomes
clear how to list them,
because we already know that the
pairs of non-negative integers
are countable.
So I'm just going to map a pair
of non-negative integers m, n
to the rational
number m divided by n.
Well, n might be
zero, so if n is zero,
just map all of those pairs to
your favorite rational number.
Call it a half.
And that gives us a
nice surjective mapping,
because every
rational number can
be expressed as m
over n-- at least
every non-negative
rational number.
So in effect, what we
have is a surjection
from the pairs of
non-negative integers, which
we know is countable, onto the
non-negative real numbers--
sorry, the non-negative rational
numbers, quotients of integers.
Which means that the
rationals, sure enough,
are countable, even
though they seem to be
spread out all over the line.
So, again, we saw that if
N cross N is countable,
and there's a surj,
described above,
to the non
non-negative rationals,
so they're countable.
Well, just looking
ahead a little bit,
it's going to turn
out that, in contrast
to the rational numbers, the
real numbers are not countable.
And in fact, neither
are the infinite binary
sequences that we
saw-- there was
a bijection between the
infinite binary sequences
and the power set of the
non-negative integers.
And both of these
are going to be
basic examples of
uncountable sets,
so sets that are not
countable, which we will be
examining in the next lecture.